islam net is raising funds to establish
a masjid and community center in norway
every person who prays there every kid
that learns about islam every youngster
that memorizes
all of this and so much more can be on
your scale of good deeds click the link
and donate what you can
sir tony blair yep
that's exactly what he's going to be
referred to from now on sir tony blair a
terrorist who lives on my right hand
side right in front of this house number
29
let's read a bit about his knighthood
that he was given awarded
for what let's read a bit about it so
anthony charles linton call me tony
blair
blair must now be called sir tony in
addition to being right honorable he is
to be the queen's companion chivalrous
and knightly he is to wear a royal
garter the highest honor the monarch can
bestow and this is his personal decision
gasps all around a petition of protest
has received almost seven hundred
thousand signatures today that's why
over a million
let's put things in perspective here
brothers and sisters yeah
if i told you guys the isis leader abu
bakr al-baghdadi is living in this very
house and it's protected usually there's
police officers they're not here today
but there's police officers usually or
maybe they're already on the way they
are coming you know to maybe
arrest me or maybe question me why am i
standing in front of this house this
individual tony blair this filthy
scumbag not sir he's a filthy scum why
is it from viscom
someone who has been many times
attempted by non-muslims citizen arrests
why because of the atrocities
committed over a million iraqis have
been butchered slaughtered
men women children of a propaganda over
a lie
of mass destruction of weapons of mass
destruction
and this is where he lives
and i just want you guys to know
brothers and sisters just imagine for a
second
if a muslim wants to commit atrocities
against
christians whoever it may be just
imagine for a second killing one million
innocent people
and he is living in peace do you think
that would have happened
they would have taken this whole block
out
this whole block would have been blown
into pieces
but we have an individual who has killed
innocent men women and children and
snorted them
blue blow them into pieces
he can casually
walk around have nice restaurants go to
nice restaurants have nice dinners spend
a lovely time with their family in their
uh property portfolio this is one of
them 27 million pounds they've got many
houses and flats it makes me sick it
should make you sick how an individual
like this can get away with it in this
life of course not in the hereafter and
you know what is very sad
is that
many individuals who are hostile
islamophobes do not even mention it you
have the ex-muslim community yeah they
talk about their rights yeah you know
they want islam wants to kill us all
that kind of nonsense yeah rubbish and
another coward that little puss in
animals which i'm going to be debating
in may and letting them know what time
it is i'm gonna make him intellectually
i'm gonna choke him intellectually
inshaallah but none of them ever talk
about this none of them ever mention
what happened in iraq
and what happens around the world to
muslims and we
are there to be called terrorists while
the real terrorist lives in this damn
house protected by police
in a 24-hour clock
it makes me sick and it just shows the
double standards of media
one million people slaughtered and
massacred i want you guys to remember
those numbers that's all i have to say
here brother sisters and
to me it's just so sad that someone like
him can get away with it by massaging
that amount of people and he lives in
his nice millions of pounds of worth of
house casually enjoying itself in the
garden may allah destroy him in this
life in the hereafter or guide him you
know but i'm inclined to destroy part
until next time brothers and sisters
do give you a feedback on how you feel
because it makes me really really sad
and sick that people like him can commit
atrocities and get away
in this life